going to have to break away from that
because the spokesman for qatar's
foreign Ministry is holding a media
conference in regards to this ceasefire
let's listen in we have just finished
with all the communication with all uh
parties in order to ascertain the lists
of uh those civilians who will be freed
as a result of the deal agreed upon by
uh by both parties the uh lists have
been handed to both sides and finally uh
in a communication just now the list has
been handed to the Israeli intelligence
service the uh the Mad in order to
facilitate the implementation of uh of
the deal the according to this of course
and as as the agreement uh took place uh
the beginning of the pause will be 7
a.m. Friday the 24th of November and it
will last of course as agreed for four
uh days and uh the first uh patch of
civilians to to be released from razza
will be around 4 p.m. of the same day
they will be 133 in number all women and
uh children and uh those hostages who
are from the same families will be uh
put together within the same patch
obviously every day will include a
number of uh of civilians has agreed to
Total 50 within the four uh days uh the
communications that took place and the
meetings that took place all through uh
yesterday went on until early morning uh
today with the Egyptians and the parties
of the conflict present here in uh in
Doha uh the meetings went very well and
in a positive uh environment and uh the
results of course was the uh
implementation plan uh of uh of the
agreement which we have always said
needed to be something that is concrete
and and uh very uh ready to uh create a
safe uh environment for the release of
of the uh the
hostages uh this is what I have here
information for you right now and uh
I'll be taking questions